c'est un festival de bruit et de
couleurs le tout fait à la main dans un
entrepôt de la presqu'île de caen on
monte en pression voici les futurs chars
que l'on retrouvera dans le cortège de
la nouvelle édition du carnaval étudiant
sept au total soit à peu près le double
de l'an passé on a cinq chars qui sont
déjà quasiment fini juste après un sa
ligne toute la déco et on a deux chars
qui arrive demain mais c'est déjà tout
est préparé dans leur école parce qu'ils
viennent pas forcément de caen on espère
juste que le beau temps sera avec nous
mais bon on verra bien à deux jours du
début du carnaval
tout roule comme aujourd'hui dans le
centre ville jeudi ce sera une toute
autre histoire à quand on affiche
clairement la couleur la présence des
quatre roues à moteur sera interdite
tout le long des deux kilomètres de
parcours y compris dans les rues
alentour à noter que ce lieu de
rassemblement des carnavaliers a été
modifiée à l'occasion de cette 21ème
édition dont le terminus sera situé au
parc des expos c'est la même chose que
l'année dernière sauf qu'au lieu de
partir défiler l'esplanade de la paix on
part place de la mare
parce qu'à cause des travaux de tram du
combat mais c'est uniquement pour cette
année et l'année prochaine on reprendra
le le tracé habituel autres
perturbations annoncées sur le réseau
des transports en commun l'axé un
secteur du centre ville étant bloquée
durant cette manifestation la
circulation sera fortement perturbé sur
certaines lignes du bus puisque nous
avons établi un plan de déviation pour
la vingtaine de lignes de bus qui sera
impacté entre 12 heures jusqu'à fin de
service alors ça n'impacte pas les
lignes nos petits bus qui vont continuer
à circuler mais par contre vous ne
trouverez pas de navette centre-ville
need express à le soir informations
pratiques à retrouver sur le site
internet
twist au point fr